manchmal verliere ich die hoffnung weil
wir nichts haben wir haben keinen vater
meine mutter kämpft für uns ich muss mir
lernen um ihr später helfen zu können
ich möchte nicht dass sie so leidet wie
jetzt wenn ich erwachsen bin möchte ich
die beste chirurgen werden so dass ich
meiner mutter helfen kann
seit wochen hat die 14-jährige schüler
kgh keinen unterricht mehr
die schulen sind wegen corona
geschlossen sie macht sich große sorgen
denn eine gute schulbildung ist ihre
einzige chance eines tages nairobis
größtem slum kibera zu entkommen
jeden morgen steht sie um sechs uhr auf
und studiert ihre hefte während sie
darauf wartet den fernseh
schulunterricht auf dem fernsehgerät bei
den nachbarn verfolgen zu können
ihre mutter sophia hunde kann ihren
kindern nicht beim homeschooling helfen
die familie hat kein laptop tablet oder
computer oft ist der strom weg sei es
auch ich kann die aufgaben nicht
überprüfen ich bin nicht zur schule
gegangen also gehen sie zu den nachbarn
die das für mich tun
wann immer chinas nachbarn zu hause sind
lernt sie dort vor dem fernseher die
angst zu viel stoff zu verpassen ist
gross und berechtigt
[Musik]
seit dem beginn der korona krise hat die
kenianische regierung zusammen mit dem
kinderhilfswerk körper ein nationen die
fern lernangebote massiv ausgeweitet um
das schlimmste zu verhindern sagt jane
interview von unicef schon vor chor wird
gab es im bildungswesen eine schwere
krise kinder waren nicht in der lage die
lernziele ihrem alter entsprechend zu
erreichen und sie können sich vorstellen
dass mit der kuba krise
das erreichen dieser ziele zum problem
wird immer wieder aber streikt das
signal auch mal wussten momente in denen
schüler die schule die lehrer vermisst
und doch gibt der fernseh unterricht
zumindest etwas halt im ungewohnten
alltag der korona krise sophia hassan
deswegen täglich bis zu zehn
nachbarkinder ein ihren fernseher in
ihrem haus in kibera zu nutzen
auch um sie jetzt in der krise vor einer
anderen bedrohung zu bewahren
das ist wichtig denn wir haben hier in
kibera so viele fälle von gewalt
häuslicher gewalt und vergewaltigung ich
versuche mein bestes um die kinder
zusammen zu holen damit sie dem nicht
ausgesetzt sind
noch sind die korona zahlen in kenia mit
einigen tausend fällen des ende juni
2020 überschaubar aber die angst bei
einem schweren ausbruch ist poe das land
hat früher relativ strenge maßnahmen
ergriffen geschlossene kirchen masken
pflicht reiseeinschränkungen
ausgangssperren die wirtschaft leidet
darunter das wachstum könnte in diesem
jahr stark einbrechen und zuletzt sind
die korona zahlen deutlich schneller
gestiegen als zuvor
auch in den slums die armenviertel in
kenias hauptstadt echten besonders unter
den corona maßnahmen viele sind auf
lebensmittelspenden angewiesen
eine frau ist den tränen nah sie hat
keine maske dabei aber die helfer
belassen es bei einer ermahnung und
versorgen sie mit dem so wichtigen paket
wie angespannt die stimmung ist zeigt
diese szene ein krankenwagen hat einen
schwach wirkenden alten mann in linz
land gebracht angeblich negativ getestet
viele hier vermuten jedoch dass er immer
noch corona krank ist die genaue
situation ist unklar
aber es reicht dass die menschen
aufgebracht sind und ihn zurück in den
rettungswagen zwinge glauben die dass
das hier eine müllkippe für corona ist
fragt einer aus der menge
fast eskaliert die situation erzählen
uns zwei zeugen am nächsten morgen das
problem der leute war wie können sie
einen cobit patienten ohne richtige
maßnahmen einfach hierher bringen er war
ein corona fall genau so wird das virus
übertragen
wir haben uns mit dem fahrer und der
polizei darauf geeinigt dass er zurück
ins krankenhaus gebracht wird denn die
menge hat gerufen zündet den wagen
anlass den krankenwagen brennen es ist
längst genau das eingetreten was viele
befürchtet haben corona in den
armenvierteln nairobis die menschen
leben dicht gedrängt hygiene halten ist
schwierig
seit zehn jahren betreut sarah diese
hier freiwillig kranke und ältere
menschen
es gibt aids und tuberkulose im slum
aber cupid 19 übertreffe alles sagt sie
vor allem die gerüchte die fake news die
unwissenheit bonner ist die schlimmste
situation
die meisten menschen verstehen corona
verstehen das virus nicht ich selber
habe angst weil ich mit vielen menschen
über gesundheitssprecher sie aufklären
will
aber du weißt nicht mit denen du es zu
tun hast und sie tragen keine masken
server bringt uns zu jacqueline odhiambo
die weiß was es heißt im slum corona zu
bekommen
aus angst vor ausgrenzung möchte sie
unerkannt bleiben
sie kam mit symptomen ins krankenhaus
wurde positiv getestet musste vier
wochen ohne besondere behandlung bleiben
sagt sie ihre kinder hat die
alleinerziehende in der zeit nicht
gesehen noch immer fühlt sich schlapp
krank kann nicht arbeiten die anderen
draußen komme mir nicht zu nahe
seit ich hier bin sie sagen sie haben
angst dass ich sie an stecke sie haben
angst vor mir
und jacqueline odhiambo hat angst vor
jedem neuen tag und der ungewissheit
woher das nächste mal für ihre vier
kinder kommen sollen hin und wieder rufe
ich meine verwandten an damit sie mir 50
schilling zum überleben schicken aber
sie sagen sie haben auch nichts wenn sie
nicht helfen dann haben wir kein essen
keiner ist gerade in der position jeden
tag zu helfen
denn jeder tag im slum ist ein kampf um
das überleben gerade jetzt zu corona
zeiten aber genauso wie jacqueline
odhiambo gibt auch china kgh nicht auf
setzt alles daran etwas aus sich zu
machen ihr ziel chirurgen zu werden zu
erreichen egal wie lange die kugel krise
andauern
[Musik]